[Applauso]
Immagino che quasi tutti abbiate
riconosciuto questo suono Adesso vorrei
che alzasse la mano se oltre ad averlo
riconosciuto via disturbato vi ha dato
un po' di fastidio a chi è che non piace
della sveglia Tanti anche lassù vi vedo
Ecco io fino a 7 anni fa avrei alzato la
mano insieme a voi e ho anche provato a
cambiare la suoneria convinta fosse
quello il problema ma evidentemente no
io odiavo svegliarmi semplicemente
perché odiavo il mio lavoro e ogni
giorno quindi facevo un countdown per
arrivare il più possibile verso sera
verso il weekend però nulla di nuovo No
penso che siano in tanti nella stessa
situazione altrimenti le centinaia
migliaia di Meme che ci sono sul web sul
lunedì su quando si è faticoso alzarsi
ogni mattina non esisterebbero Ecco
perché allora proprio io sono qui oggi
su questo palco a provare a convincervi
che far coesistere lavoro e felicità non
sia un'utopia perché ho cambiato non mi
piaceva il mio il mio lavoro e l'ho
cambiato come diceva Emma e Come avrete
letto nella mia descrizione tra gli
speaker di oggi Io vivo di viaggio
quindi magari a qualcuno è venuto
naturale pensare Ecco l'ennesima
Wonderland affetto da questa sindrome
del viaggio che Molla tutto Zaino in
spalla un biglietto di sola andata per
il sud est asiatico magari Eva a cercare
se stessa e ci racconterà di questo no
non è andata così questa non è la mia
storia la mia storia è molto più normale
Io ero una persona
normale che odiava il suo lavoro
semplicemente non avevo abbastanza
solida parte in quel momento della mia
vita per permettermi di mollare tutto e
andare via a cercare chissà cosa nel
mondo e poi aveva una famiglia alle
spalle che non volevo deludere perché
già dovevano accusare il durissimo colpo
di vedermi sterzare all'improvviso da
una carriera che sembrava avviata
promettente Insomma mi vedevano
sistemata Come si suol dire quindi non
potevo dire ciao mamma prendo e vado e
quindi cosa ho fatto in modo molto
semplice mi sono rimboccata le maniche
ho sistemato il mio curriculum è vero Il
mio sogno era viaggiare e mi sono
chiesta come faccio e ho trovato
risposta nel turismo ho capito cosa
rendeva me è felice e ho cercato un
settore lavorativo che mi permettesse di
esserlo Ecco perché allora È così
complicato Io non ho semplicemente
cambiato lavoro non è affatto semplice
In realtà io il coraggio l'ho trovato in
maniera un po' brusca devo dire ci fu
una sveglia
quella del 16 maggio del 2016 che
nonostante fosse un lunedì non mi pesò
svegliarmi Io all'epoca vivevo a Milano
Lavoravo per una grossa multinazionale
nel settore della pubblicità online era
una delle menti strategiche che sta
dietro la pianificazione delle campagne
pubblicitarie
iodiavo talmente tanto il mio lavoro che
Piuttosto che andare in ufficio sarei
andata all'ospedale e così feci in
quello lunedì mattina io presi mezza
giornata libera e fissai una visita al
ginocchio all'ospedale di Monza
Ecco io quell'ospedale non ci arrivai
mai
Andai però un altro ospedale portato da
un'ambulanza perché proprio quel mattino
un grosso fuoristrada distrusse la mia
piccola macchina con me dentro
Ovviamente in tangenziale a Milano
Come ti chiami No non lo so perché non
risponde Come ti chiami
dire che non è facile farmi stare zitta
eh nella vita e io da quella macchina
uscìlles non mi successe quasi nulla a
livello fisico ero sveglia e cosciente
ma ero entrata in uno stato di shock
tale che non riuscivo a rispondere
neanche alla più banale delle domande
Come ti chiami non ero capace di dire il
mio nome era come se in quel momento io
avessi preso coscienza di tutti gli
eventi che quella tragedia perché ai
miei occhi era una tragedia aveva
innescato la macchina distrutta e non so
come ripagarla E come farò a muovermi
Oggi pomeriggio avevo una call il
cliente casino panico totale
quello che però ci vuole qualche giorno
a realizzare e che Jessica in quella
macchina effettivamente ci morì davvero
io quel giorno morì perché toccai con
mano Involontariamente il qui e ora io
capii che veramente oggi ci sei e forse
domani non ci sei più ma non perché te
la stai cercata perché ti sei messo in
pericolo perché è un distratto
dal telefono in autostrada non vede che
stai frenando E nel vero senso della
parola ti incula
e se ti va bene lo puoi raccontare se
non ti va bene Game Over e quindi io io
fui portata a farmi una domanda Ma se
fosse stato veramente il mio Game Over
io sarei stata contenta di aver vissuto
fino a quel giorno Ovviamente se mi
pesava svegliarmi la risposta
la risposta era no io adesso vorrei
farvi un sondaggio e verrebbe naturale
pensare che sto per chiedervi di alzare
la mano se siete felici però so che ci
sono coppie in sala Non vorrei che uno
Alza la mano l'altro no diventa un po'
complicato da gestire a casa Secondo me
Altro che game over Quindi per favore
alzate la mano se almeno una volta nella
vita avete interrotto un film Cioè
esservi addormentati non vale cioè
proprio avete iniziato a guardarlo ma
non vi è piaciuto e avete smesso di
guardarlo qualcuno c'è
in tanti cavolo
Allora non state dormendo alzate la mano
se invece avete interrotto un libro
dopo qualche capitolo avete capito che
non era così interessante Ok siamo
entrati in galleria adesso qua secondo
me ci sarà proprio standing ovation
alziamo la manos abbiamo interrotto
almeno una serie TV magari abbiamo visto
qualche episodio magari la prima
stagione però non l'abbiamo finita non
per mancanza di tempo ma non ci piaceva
Ecco io mi sembra di aver visto tutti
alzare la mano almeno una delle tre
volte e basandomi sulla statistica darò
per scontato che c'è almeno una persona
in sala questa sera che non è felice
Ecco io parlo a te
a te che già dalla prima sveglia del
mattino inizia a bestemmiare e non vedi
l'ora che arrivi sera ma quelle due ore
di sera che ti rimangono quelle dure
libere non sei disposto a sprecarle per
un film o una serie TV che non ti
interessa che non ti piace quello no
però buttare ogni giorno della tua vita
in qualcosa che non solo non ami ma
forse addirittura odi quello va bene
quello è lecito so che il paragone è un
po' azzardato Però di questo si tratta
di buttare l'unica vita che per quanto
ne sappiamo abbiamo a disposizione in
qualcosa che non non ci soddisfa non ci
rende felici di svegliarci perché
purtroppo che ci piacciono oggi il
lavoro prende la stragrande maggioranza
della nostra vita
io io sono convinta che non sia così
utopico decidere di fare un cambiamento
sono qua a parlarvene ma mi sono resa
conto che non mi sono neanche ancora
presentata Io sono Jessica Barbieri ho
31 anni e sono cresciuta in un
piccolissimo paese di provincia
Consandolo non fa neanche comune in
mezza campagna qui fuori nel ferrarese
ho fatto liceo scientifico poi mi sono
laureata in marketing ed economia Anche
se ormai al giorno d'oggi l'unica
economia che faccio è quella per
viaggiare il più possibile anche nel
tempo libero
dico Anche perché da sette anni a questa
parte Io ho iniziato a lavorare nel
turismo faccio la Tour leader di viaggi
di gruppo vuol dire che semplicemente Io
porto gruppi di persone in viaggio mi
occupo di tutta la logistica
dell'itinerario di far sì che vada tutto
bene durante le loro ferie e così
rispondo a quella che oggi è la domanda
più gettonata della mia vita perché
molti vedono il più profilo Instagram
pieno di foto di viaggio e mi chiedono
Ma come fai a viaggiare così tanto ma
più che altro come fai a permettertelo
io rispondo che è il mio lavoro Lavoro
nel turismo non è un hobby mi pagano per
farlo a questo punto parte quella che è
la seconda frase più gettonata della mia
vita che è letteralmente Grazie al cazzo
che sei felice stai sempre in vacanza
non vi sfugge niente
Allora questa sveglia Non era una scelta
artistica ma visto l'orario Ho visto
qualche palpebra calante in sala volevo
svegliarvi signori la sveglia continua a
esserci nella mia vita con quella stessa
suoneria iper mega fastidiosa A volte
anche alle 4 del mattino per prendere un
aereo o iniziare un'escursione ma non mi
pesa e non mi pesa perché sono sempre in
vacanza perché che ci crediate o no è
anche il mio è un lavoro vero è fatto di
di tanti sacrifici fatica
rinunce pur sempre un lavoro quello che
da fuori sembra essere sempre in vacanza
che non è altro che la punta di un
grosso iceberg dal primo gennaio ad oggi
quindi in circa otto mesi ha implicato
per me prendere 61 voli dire quasi due
alla settimana avrei mangiato quasi 400
volte al ristorante e aver dormito 200
volte in un letto che non era il mio e
sembra che sono appena usciti cervicale
colesterolo dalla sala
ma non ho neanche coltivato un hobby non
Ho praticato uno sport ma soprattutto
mia sorella ha preso il suo primo aereo
senza la famiglia io non ero in
aeroporto a salutarla la mia migliore
amica si è laureata non ero alla sua
festa mio cugino ha battezzato suo
figlio e non ero neanche a quella di
festa non ci sono quasi mai
Eppure io non mi lamento io non mi
lamento perché io così sono felice io ho
trovato come chiudere il mio bilancio
della mia vita lavorativa in positivo
che Ricordiamoci che è pur sempre un
lavoro quindi ci sarà sempre dei contro
delle cose che ci piacciono un po' di
meno però io ho capito come far sì che i
miei pro siano tanti di più
e io capisco che magari uno ce l'ha
chiaro no cosa cosa lo rende felice
quali sarebbe il lavoro dei suoi sogni e
allora qual è l'altro problema che ci
impedisce di inseguire la strada giusta
un'altra cosa che amo del mio lavoro
sono le persone e i legami che riesco a
creare con loro e quindi userò le parole
di una delle ragazze che ha viaggiato
con me per spiegare perché è così
difficile inseguire il proprio sogno
questa ragazza aveva appena vent'anni
quindi ne ha 21 non è ancora lì e ha
lasciato questa dedica in questo
quaderno che appunto io passo a fine
viaggio e mi hanno colpito molto le sue
parole e ci spiegherà lei cosa è
complicato
leggerò la parte evidenziata Se volete
seguire con me è un po' il fulcro del
suo messaggio
Oggi giorno di rientro credo di essere
giunta da una conclusione No non sono
soddisfatta della mia vita e penso
sempre che manchi qualcosa da quando
sono piccola è stato un continuo
accontentarsi di tutto ciò che mi
circondava
Vorrei arrivare al punto di fregarmene
altamente e smettere di pensare quale
giudizio gli altri possono darmi vorrei
raggiungere un equilibrio
senza sentire il peso di ogni mia
decisione
il peso di ogni sua decisione Ma chi è
che ci fa sentire il peso di Ogni nostra
decisione
sei sprecata se non fai l'università
Mi raccomando Pensaci due volte prima di
iniziare il lavoro o cambiare il lavoro
forse non è che non vuoi un figlio
Magari è solo perché non hai ancora
trovato la persona giusta
stai scappando da qualcosa Vedrai che
quando l'hai trovato Ti fermerai
e forse questo il peso della società
queste frasi io non le ho lette sui
giornali e non le ho sentite in
televisione queste frasi me le hanno
dette i miei prof la mia famiglia i miei
amici Le persone che più mi vogliono
bene perché sono proprio quelli che ci
circondano che ci condizionano e noi
condizioniamo loro è proprio chi ci
vuole più bene ci ama che però non perde
occasione ogni giorno per ricordarci che
essere felici un'utopia che è meglio il
posto fisso piuttosto che il lavoro dei
tuoi sogni
non serve essere una persona coraggiosa
per cambiare basta esserlo per 20
secondi 20 secondi per dire al capo che
ti licenzi 20 secondi per dire a tua
madre che studierai filosofia e non
medicina come vuole lei 20 secondi per
dire alla tua ragazza che vuoi andare in
Australia a lavorare è giusto
contrastare l'opinione degli altri anche
se quegli altri possono essere tuo padre
tuo fratello il tuo migliore amico
è giusto cambiare giusto evolvere
viviamo in una società che cambia
velocemente i lavori che ci sono oggi
fino a 5 anni fa non esistevano abbiamo
ogni informazione a portata di mano ogni
angolo del mondo e a distanza di un
click e allora facciamolo cambiamo
esploriamo
io quando ho trovato questo lavoro non
sapevo se sarebbe stato giusto per me Io
sono andata per tentativi l'ho provato
Come si prova un paio di scarpe che
sullo scaffale sembra bellissimo ma
finché non lo provi non sai se sarà
comodo o se sarà bello su di te
è giusto cambiare come vi dicevo prima è
giusto contrastare quello che pensano
gli altri Io ad esempio l'opinione dei
miei genitori lo contrastata
innumerevoli volte mamma e papà che sono
qui in sala possono confermare questa
cosa Eppure nonostante io sia andata
quasi sempre avanti di testa mia
inseguendo quello che secondo me era il
mio ideale di felicità una delle frasi
più importanti più importanti della mia
vita me l'ha detta proprio mia madre e
io avevo 17 anni Stavo per partire per
la mia più importante esperienza di
studio all'estero stavo per andare negli
Stati Uniti e non ci saremmo riviste per
sei mesi la cosa mi metteva chiaramente
molto in crisi e la mia mamma se ne
accorse Mi guardò
e mi disse e non ho bisogno di averla
scritta da nessuna parte questa frase
perché è ben scolpita qui e qui
non devi avere paura
non sarai mai da sola perché con te ci
sarà sempre Jessica lei non mi disse ci
sarò io non disse saremo sempre con te
saremo nel tuo cuore
ero io che sarei stata con me stessa
sono io la mia migliore amica la persona
che può consolarmi che mi conosce meglio
che conosce i miei segreti che sa cosa
mi rende felice io sono la prima persona
con cui devo condividere la vita e sono
anche l'ultima è l'unica persona a cui
dovrò rendere il conto finale
io e penso la maggior parte di voi qui
in sala siamo persone normali non
finiremo sui libri di storia e non ci
saranno aeroporti intitolati con il
nostro nome
vi dirò di più io dei miei otto bisnonni
saprai dirvi tre nomi e non saprei
nominarvi nessuno dei miei trisavoli non
me li ricordo quindi non solo l'umanità
si dimenticherà di me ma lo faranno
persino le generazioni Sangue del mio
sangue quindi
al netto del rispetto per gli altri e
per il mondo e l'ambiente in cui viviamo
perché al centro della tua vita non deve
esserci la tua felicità
E se invece sei già felice se stai bene
se quel cambiamento Lo sta cercando
qualcuno che ti stacca accanto per
favore non ostacolarlo non mettergli i
bastoni tra le ruote Non ricordargli che
essere felici e trovare un lavoro che
renda felice un'utopia perché non è vero
supportalo aiutalo dagli quella carica
in più che gli serve per cambiare perché
ora di svegliarsi ed essere felici di
svegliarsi
[Applauso]
[Musica]